all right good morning we're gonna go
ahead and get started
homework 1 is due today unless you're
using late days and homework 2 will be
released today homework 2 is gonna be
over function approximation and
reinforcement learning I'm we're gonna
start to cover that material today and
then we'll continue next week with deep
learning deep learning is not a
prerequisite for this class and so we're
gonna be releasing a tutorial on
tensorflow
later this week and then next week we'll
also in sessions have the opportunity to
go into some more of the background of
deep learning you're not expected to be
an expert at it but you need to know
enough of it in order to do the
homeworks and do the function
approximation we will be assuming that
you're very familiar with things like
gradient descent and taking derivatives
and things like that
tensor flow and other packages can do
that automatically for you but you
should be familiar with the general
process that it happens before we
continue to then may have any logistic
questions alright let's go ahead and get
started
as you can see I have lost my voice a
little bit it's coming back but we'll
see how we go and if it gets too tricky
and impacts and we'll take over all
right so what we've been talking about
so far is thinking about learning to be
able to evaluate policies and sequential
decision making cases and being able to
make decisions all of this is when the
world is unknown and what I mean by that
is that we're not given in advance a
dynamics model or a reward model and
what we're going to start to talk about
today is value function approximation
just so I know actually who of the who
do you've seen this before we've seen
some form of like value function
approximation okay so a couple people
but most people know I so when I say
value function approximation what I mean
is that so far we've been thinking about
domains where we tend to have a finite
set of states and actions and where it
is computationally and memory feasible
to just write down a table to keep track
of what the value is of States or the
value of state action pairs or that we
could imagine writing down a table to
write down the models explicitly of the
reward model in the dynamics model
many real-world problems have enormous
state and action spaces so if you think
about things like the Atari games which
we can debate about whether or not
that's a real-world problem but it's
certainly a challenging problem the
state space we discussed the beginning
is really through the set of pixels and
so that's going to be an enormous space
and we're not going to be able to write
down that as a table and so in these
cases we're gonna have to go beyond sort
of this tabular representation and
really think about this issue of
generalization so we're gonna need to be
able to say we want to be able to make
decisions and learn to make a decisions
we're gonna need to be able to
generalize from our prior experience so
that even if we end up in a state action
pair that we've never seen exactly
before it's like a slightly different
set of pixels than we've ever seen
before
that we're still going to be able to
make good decisions and that's going to
require generalization so what we're
going to talk about today is their
starting with value function
approximation for prediction and then
talk about control and the kind of the
key idea that we're gonna start to talk
about in this case is that we're going
to be representing the state action
value value function with a parametrized
function so we can think of now is
having a function where we input a state
and instead of looking up in a table to
see what its value is instead we're
gonna have some parameters here so this
is this could be a deep neural network
this could be you know a polynomial it
could be all sorts of different function
approximations but the key here is that
we have some parameters that allow us to
say for any input state what is the
value and just like we saw before we're
gonna both sort of go back and forth
between thinking of there being a state
value function and a state action value
function and the key thing now is that
we have these parameters and we're
mostly going to be talking about those
parameters in terms of W so you could
generally think of W is just a vector hi
where that vector could be the
parameters of a deep neural network or
it could be something much simpler
so again you know why do we want to do
this and sort of what are the forms of
approximations we might start to think
about so we just don't want to have
explicitly store learn for every
individual state action pair so we don't
have to do that in terms of learning
dynamics model we don't have to do that
in terms of a value function or state
action value function or even in terms
of a policy I'm gonna need to be able to
generalize so that we can figure out
that our agents our algorithms can
figure out good policies for sort of
these enormous state spaces and action
spaces so we need these compact
representations so once we do this we're
gonna get multiple different benefits
that we're also going to incur potential
problems as well so we're gonna reduce
the memory that we need to store all of
these things we're gonna reduce the
computation needed and we might be able
to reduce the experience and so what I
mean by that there is how much data does
our agent need to collect in order to
learn to make good decisions so this is
really a notion of sort of how much data
is needed now I just wanna highlight
here that um you know there can be
really bad be really bad approximations
and those can be great in terms of not
leaving a lot of data and not need a lot
of computation and not need a lot of
memory but they may just not allow you
to represent very good policies so these
are these choices of representation are
defining in sort of hypothesis classes
they're defining spaces over which you
couldn't represent policies and value
functions and so you could there's gonna
be sort of a bias variance trade-off
here and at a function approximation
trade-off in the sense that if you have
a very small representation you're not
going to need very much data to learn to
fit it but then it's also not going to
have very good capacity in terms of
representing complicated value functions
or policies so as a simple example we
could assume that our agent is always in
the same state all the time you know all
video game frames are always identical
and that's a really compressed
representation you know we only have one
state but it's not gonna allow us to
learn to make different decisions in
different parts of the game so it's not
gonna allow us to achieve high reward
so there's going to generally be a
trade-off between the capacity of the
representation we choose so sort of the
representational capacity versus all
these other things we would like versus
memory computation and data now there
isn't always sometimes one gets lucky
and you can you choose something that's
very very compact and it's still
sufficient to represent the properties
you need to represent it in order to
make good decisions but it's just we're
thinking that often there's this
explicit trade-off and we often don't
know in advance what is a sufficient
representational capacity in order to
achieve high reward yeah is this more or
less in orthogonal consideration from
the bias-variance tradeoff in in a
functional denomination yeah you can
think of it as right it's been as
question is whether this is an
orthogonal trade-off to sort of
bias-variance tradeoff good may give it
is related if you choose a really
restricted representational capacity
you're gonna have a bias forever because
you're just not going to be able to
represent the true function so it's and
then you'll have considered a smaller
variance for a long time because it's a
smaller representation so it's related
to relate to that if you've taken
machine learning and talked about things
like structural risk minimization and
thinking about how you choose your model
class capacity versus how much data you
have in terms of minimizing your tests
that are similar to that too so you know
how do you trade-off in terms of
capacity to generalize versus the
expressive power all right so a natural
immediate question that we've started I
started alluding to already is what
function approximation are we gonna use
there's a huge number of choices today
we're only gonna start to talk about one
particular set but there's an enormous
number probably most the ones you can
think of have been tried with
reinforcement learning so pretty much
anything that you could do in supervised
learning you could also try as a
function approximator for your value
function could be neural networks or
deep decision trees or nearest neighbors
wavelet basis
lots of
things what we're gonna do in this class
is mostly focus on things that are
differentiable
these are nice for a number of reasons
but they tend to be have really nice
smooth optimization properties so
they're easier to optimize for that's
one of the reasons for him to focus on
them in this class those are not always
the right choice I can every give me
example of where for those of you that
are familiar with decision trees where
you might want a decision tree to
represent either your value function or
your policy yeah
they can be how the interpretive
all-defensive is exactly so what's just
said is that you know depending on where
how you're using this sort of
reinforcement learning policy this may
be interacting directly with people so
let's say this is going to be used as a
decision support for doctors in those
cases having a deep neural network may
not be very effective in terms of
justifying why you want a particular
treatment for a patient but if you use a
decision tree those tend to be highly
interpretable well depending on which
features you use but often it's pretty
highly interpretive and so that can be
really helpful so thinking about what
function approximation you use often
depends on how you're going to use it
later on there's also been some really
expanding and exciting work recently on
sort of explainable deep neural networks
where you can fit a deep neural network
and then you can fit a sort of a simpler
function approximator on top so you
could fit like first fit your deep
neural network and then try to fit a
decision tree to it so you try to get
the kind of the best of both worlds
super expressive function approximator
and then still get the interpret ability
later but it's worth thinking about sort
of the application that you're looking
at because different ones will be more
appropriate in different cases so you
know probably the two most popular
classes these days and in RL in general
are linear value function approximation
and deep neural networks and we're going
to start with linear value function
approximation for two reasons
one is that it's been sort of probably
the most well studied function
approximator in reinforcement learning
but up to the last few years and second
is because you can think of deep neural
networks as computing some really
complicated set of features that you're
then doing linear function approximation
over at least in the number of cases so
it sort of provides a nice foundation
for the next part anyway all right so
we're gonna do a really quick review of
gradient descent because we're gonna be
using it a ton over the next few days so
let's just think about any sort of
general function J which is a
differentiable function of a parameter
vector W so you have some vector W it's
gonna be a set of linear weights soon
and our goal is to find the parameter W
that minimizes our objective function I
haven't told you what the objective
function is
to find it shortly so the gradient of J
of W is we're gonna denote that as Delta
J of W and that's just us taking the
derivative of it of it with respect to
each of the parameters inside of the
vector and so that would be the gradient
and so a gradient descent way of trying
to optimize for a function J of W would
be to compute the derivative or the
gradient of it and then to move your
parameter vector in the direction of the
gradient so if your weights and
generally we're going to is always
assumed the weights are a vector and I
are gonna be equal to your previous
value of the weights minus some learning
rate of the derivative of your objective
function so we're sort of just we're
figuring out the derivative of our
function and then we're going to take a
step size and that and move our
parameter weights over a little bit and
then we're gonna keep going so if we do
this enough times are we guaranteed to
find a local Optima right so so assume
it yeah so they could meet yeah there
may be some conditions on the learning
rate i but yes if we do this enough
we're guaranteed to get to a local
optima now notice this is local so when
we start thinking about this in terms of
apollos in terms of doing RL it's
important to think about where are we
going to converge to and if we're gonna
converge and I'll talk more about that
throughout class so this is going to be
sort of a local way for us to try to
smoothly start changing our parameter
representation of the value function in
order to try to get to a better better
approximation of it all right so let's
think about how this would apply if
we're trying to do policy evaluation
so again policy evaluation if someone's
given you a policy
given you a mapping of first date what
your action is and this could be it
could be stochastic so it could be a
mapping from States to a probability
distribution over actions so but
someone's given you a policy and what
you want to do is figure out what's the
value of that policy
what's the expected discount a sum of
rewards you get by following that policy
so let's assume for a second that we
could carry a particular state and then
an Oracle would just give us the value
the true value of the policy so I you
know I ask you like you know what's the
what's the expected discount of summer
of returns first starting in this part
of the room and trying to navigate
towards the door under some policy and
it says okay the expected discounted
number of steps it would take you is on
average like 30 for example so that
would be a way that the Oracle could
return these pairs and so you'd get sort
of this pair of s V PI of s and then
let's say given that we have all this
data what we want to do is we want to
fit a function we want to fit our
parameterize function to represent all
that data accurately so we want to find
the best representation in our space of
the state value pairs so if you frame
this in the context of stochastic
gradient descent what we're gonna want
to do is just directly try to minimize
our loss between the value that we're
predicting and the true value so right
now imagine someone's giving us these
true s value pairs and then we just want
to fit a function approximator to fit
that data so it's really very similar to
just doing sort of supervised learning
and in general we're going to use the
mean squared loss and we'll return to
that later so the mean squared loss in
this case is that we're just going to
compare the true value to our
approximate value and our approximate
value here is parameterized by our
vector of parameters and we're just
gonna do gradient descent so we're gonna
compute the derivative of our objective
function and when we do compute the
derivative of that then we're going to
take a step size and we're gonna do
stochastic gradient descent here which
means we're just gonna sample the
gradient
so what I mean by that is that if we
take the derivative of our objective
function what we would get as we'd get
something that looks like this and what
we're going to do is we're going to take
I'm going to use this as shorthand for
updating the weights we're going to take
a small step size in the direction of
this as evaluated for one single point
so now there's no expectation and this
is just for a single point so this is
stochastic gradient descent where we're
not trying to compute the average of
this gradient we're kunda we're trying
to just sample this gradient evaluated
at particular States and what I've told
you right now is that someone's given us
these pairs of states and the true value
function so you just take one of those
pairs compute the gradient at that point
and then update your wave function and
do that many many times and the nice
thing is that the expected stochastic
gradient descent is the same as the full
gradient update so this has nice
properties in terms of converging yes a
named purse please
so just a confirm wised expectation over
policy and not over a set of states if
you were saying that perhaps GT is a
single state so this is over the
distribution of states that you don't
counter under this policy discussion was
you know what why do it over what does
the expectation mean in this case in
this case it's the expected distribution
of states and values you'd get under
this policy and that's an important
point will come up later it'll come up
again later in terms of sort of what is
the distribution of data that you're
going to encounter under a policy of
course you know in reality we don't
actually have access to an Oracle to
tell us the true value function for any
state if we did we would already know
the true value function and we wouldn't
need to do anything else so what we're
gonna do now is talk about how do we do
model free function approximation in
order to do your prediction evaluation
without a model
okay so if we go back to what we talked
about before we thought about either
these sort of Monte Carlo style methods
or these TD learning style methods where
we could adaptively learn online a value
function to represent the value of
following a particular policy and we did
this using data and we're gonna do
exactly the same thing now except for
we're gonna have to whenever we're doing
this sort of update step of do updating
our estimator with new data we're also
going to have to do function
approximation so instead of just like
incrementally updating our table entry
about the value of a state now we also
have to really our function whenever we
get new data all right so when we start
doing this we're gonna have to choose a
feature vector to represent the state
let me just ground out what this might
mean so let's imagine that we're
thinking about a robot and our robot
that well robots kinda have tons of
really amazing sensors but let's imagine
that it's old-school and it just has a
laser rangefinder a lot of laser
rangefinders used to basically be 180
degrees and so you would get distance to
the first obstacle that you hit along
all of this 180 degrees so maybe here
it's like two feet and this is one point
five feet this is seven feet and it sort
of gives you an approximation of what
the wall looks like for example so
here's our robot it's giving it's got a
sensor on it which is the laser
rangefinder and it's telling us the
distance to all of the walls and so what
would this feature representation be in
this case it would just recently for
each of these a hundred and eighty
degrees what's the distance at one
degree degree that be example of a
feature representation now why that
sounds like a pretty good it's maybe
slightly primitive but generally a
pretty good feature representation but
what's the problem with that well
probably isn't Markov so a lot of
buildings have hallways that would say
you know on my left on my right there's
a wall about two feet away and then
there's nothing in front of me at least
four perhaps out to my laser rangefinder
say you know out of range and that would
be true for many different parts of the
same hallway and it would be true for
many different hallways and so there'd
be a lot of partial aliasing so this is
a feature representation that probably
is not Markoff but it might be
reasonable it might be a reasonable one
on which to condition decisions maybe if
you're in the middle of the hallway and
that's what it looks like you always
just want to go forward that's an
example of a type of feature
representation and again just emphasizes
the point that the choice of the feature
representation will end up being really
important and for those of you who have
taken in through deep learning classes
you've probably already heard this but
it's kind of before deep learning there
was often I'm not a huge amount of work
there's still a huge amount of work on
doing feature engineering to figure out
what's the right way to write down your
state space so that you could make
predictions or make decisions and one of
the nice things about deep neural
networks is that it kind of pushes back
that feature selection problem so you
can use really high dimensional sensor
input and then do less amount of hand
tuning so what do I mean by hand tuning
well in this case you know you could use
the raw features about like how far you
are to on each of these hundred and
eighty degrees or you can imagine having
higher-level abstract features like
trying to understand if there are
corners so you could already have done
some pre-processing on this raw data to
figure out what features you think might
be relevant if you're gonna make
decisions and the problem with doing
that is that it again if you if you pick
the wrong set you might not be able to
make the decisions you want yes the name
first please
yeah so question is can i elaborate why
this is not Markov I if you just have
180 degrees for a robot if you think
about something say like a long hallway
let's say this is floor one this is
floor - like in gates for example so if
you have your little robot that's
walking along and it's guiding its laser
rangefinder it's trying to tell it's the
distance to all of the things you're not
going to be able to distinguish with
that representation whether you're on
floor 1 or floor 2 because your
immediate sensor readings are going to
look identical and in fact you're not
you're able to tell where you are in
that hallway from its lot way yeah so
can we generalize that if you have
postulate is then we say it's normal
question is can we generalize and say if
we have partial aliasing it's not Markov
yes like I mean you could change the
state representation to be Markov by
including the history and so then each
individual observation would be aliased
but the whole state representation would
not be but in general I guess if you
have a state representation for which
there is a Lea C and it's not Markov
might still be that you could still do
pretty well with that representation or
you might not but it's just good to be
aware of in terms of the techniques one
is applying good questions all right so
let's think about doing this with linear
value of function approximation so what
do I mean by linear value function
approximation it means that we're simply
gonna have a set of weights and we're
gonna dot product this with a set of
features so you know maybe it's my
hundred and eighty degrees sensor
readings and then I'm just gonna have a
weight for each of those 180 features
and we can either represent a value
function or you can do that for a state
action value function those of you
already thinking about state action
value functions might notice that
there's at least two ways to do that
once you start getting into Q just
mention that briefly you could either
have a separate weight vector for each
action or you could put the action as
sort of an additional feature
essentially multiple different choices
you get different forms of Shari
but right now we're just thinking about
estimating the value of a particular
policy so we're just gonna think about
values and we're gonna say that remember
W is a vector and X is a vector now X of
s is just going to give us the features
of that state so it could be like the
real state of the world is where the
robot is and the features you get out
are those 180 readings so we're again
going to focus on mean squared error our
objective function is this mean squared
error the difference between the values
were predicting and the true values and
this is our weight update which is we
want to update our weight by a learning
rate times the derivative of this
function so what does this look like in
the case of linear value function
approximation so what we're gonna do is
we're just going to take the derivative
of J using the fact that we know that
this is actually x times W okay so what
we're going to get in this case is W
Delta W is equal to it's 1/2 alpha to be
PI of s minus V yes W times X because
the derivative of x times W with respect
to W is X yes great question at her I'm
Union one more time yes question is is
this as an expected value of or all
states or a particular state when we're
doing the update of the W we're going to
be evaluating this at one state so we're
gonna do this for each state so we're
gonna see different algorithms for it
but generally we're going to be doing
stochastic gradient descent so we're
gonna be doing this at each state the
expected value here you can think about
is really over the state distribution
sampled from this policy so if you were
to execute this policy in your real MDP
you would encounter some states and if
you and we'll talk to shortly more about
like what that distribution looks like
but that's the we want to minimize our
error over all over the state
distribution we would encounter under
that policy hi good questions ok so if
we look at this forum what does this
look like it looks like we have a step
size
we've seen before with TD learning and
then we have a prediction error which is
the difference between the value
function the true value function and the
value function we're predicting under
estimator and then we have a feature
value so that's one of the nice aspects
of linear linear value function
approximation is that these updates form
into this sort of very natural notion of
how far off were you from the true value
well we're gonna push this into either
so question is about just being careful
about the negatives that come out yes
you could push that negative out into
here in general alpha is a constant so
you can flip it and be positive or
negative generally you're gonna want
your if you're minimizing this it's
gonna be you're gonna be subtracting
this from the weights but you just want
to be careful of depending on how you're
defining your alpha so make sure you're
taking gradients a sense of a gradient
steps in the right direction
okay so how would we do this remembering
again that we don't actually have access
to the true value function so we don't
actually know so in this equation right
this assumes this is true like this is
if the Oracle has given you the value of
a state under that policy but of course
we don't have access to that so what
we're gonna do is sort of use the same
types of ideas as what we saw in tabular
learning now with the value function
approximation so the return which is the
expected or the return which is the sum
of rewards from time step T till the end
of the episode is an unbiased noisy
sample of the true expected return for
the current state right on time step T
and so we can think about doing Monte
Carlo value function approximation as
really as if we're doing supervised
learning on a set of state return pairs
so now what we're doing here is we're
substituting in GT
estimate of the true value so we don't
know what the true value is but we know
that the Monte Carlo returned is an
unbiased estimator so we're going to
substitute that in okay so what does
that mean if we're doing linear value
function approximation
it means inside of our weight update we
have a G here so we would take the state
we would take the sum of rewards on that
episode so again this it can only be
applied in episodic settings just like
generally with Monte Carlo and then we
take the derivative and in this case
that's just X our features because we're
using a linear value function
approximation and then on the last line
I'm just plugging in exactly what our V
hat estimator is so we're comparing our
return to our current estimator and then
we're multiplying it by our features and
as usual we have the problem that G
might be a very noisy estimate at the
return yes the name first please read
the first rate first time inevitably
before that do we differentiate first
time and every time is it like before
great vision do we distinguish between
first time visited every time visit yes
the same exact distinctions apply to
Monte Carlo updating that applied before
so on here I'm showing a first visit
variant of it but you could also could
also do every visit and it would have
the same strengths and limitations as
before every visit is biased
asymptotically it's consistent okay so
what does the weights look like in this
case we would say weight is equal to the
old weights plus alpha times e T of s
minus V don't tell me you remembering
that this is just x times W for that
state times X of s
so it's very similar to what we saw
before for Monte Carlo a parks a Monte
Carlo policy evaluation what we do is we
start off in this case now instead of
having a value function we just have a
set of weights which is going to now be
the zero vector to start then we sample
an episode we have to simple all the way
to the end of the episode using the
policy and then we step through that
episode and if it's the first visit to
that state then we compute the return
from that state till the end of the
episode and then we update our weights
question is about the Alpha where o in
terms of negative versus positive yeah
so in general this is gonna look like
this I'm gonna be a little bit loose on
those alpha is gonna be a learning rate
that's a choice generally we're gonna be
trying to minimize my objective function
we're gonna be reducing our weeks and
we'll use Biel again be a little bit
careful about how we pick alpha over
time and and this is being evaluated at
each of the states that we encounter
along the way
and just
be careful on steps it you know camera
or just notice good question and on step
also I said do we need to have a gamma
function it's a good question in
episodic RL you can always get away with
gamma being one so if it's an episodic
place gamma can always equal one it is
also fine to include gamma here so here
generally in episodic cases you will set
a gamma being equal to one because one
of the reasons ways that our gamma to be
less than one is to make sure things are
bounded in terms of their value function
but in the episodic case it is always
guaranteed to be bounded but it is also
completely fine to include a gamma here
about the same point about G so when we
do that it seems like we will end up
sentient G's that have reward rewards
over episodes of different things right
so doesn't that cause they're
distributed stationary no there's a
problem with the fact that the returns
you're taking are gonna be some so for
different lengths it isn't so I you're
always trying to estimate the value of
being in this state which itself under
this policy and in the episodic case you
might encounter that state early on in
the trajectory or late in the trajectory
and your your value is exactly going to
be averaged over with you in Canada
early or late and one of the returns
there's no problem with we're assuming
all of your episodes are bounded they
have to be finite so they're you know
has to be with probability one your
episode has to end if that is true then
your your rewards are always bounded and
then you can always just average over
this and that's fine sometimes you might
encounter a state really early in the
trajectory and have a lot of rewards
other times you might encounter at the
end and have very few rewards and the
value of it just the expectation
one has proper education so essentially
this argument you're updating this
little of the linear approximation happy
episode so you sometimes it'll give us
look then you take that's a little new
updated yet not just once I suppose in
you're not just updating the wait once
an episode many times right so you look
at all the states you encounter at that
episode and for each of those you update
your weight vector generating all the
assets and trying to keep them that's it
you know what if we did this in a batch
setting so what if you generated all
irradiator and then afterwards tried to
fit it so this is an incremental
approach to doing that um and they'll
end up converging to the same thing yeah
just when you click image shooting gamma
to the power J minus T so that you start
discounting like going forwards
again you shouldn't need a gamma in this
case so in general in this case there
should be probably knows that I'm
there'd be no gamma if in the episodic
case it's good to be precise about these
settings okay all right so let's think
about this for a particular example it
turns out that when we start to combine
function approximation with making
decisions and doing this sort of
incremental update online things can
start to go bad and there's a and what I
mean by bad is that we may not converge
and where you may not converge to places
that we want to in terms of representing
the optimal value function so there's a
nice example when people are really
starting to think a lot about function
approximation in the early 1990s beared
came up with this example where it can
illustrate some of the challenges of
doing function approximation when
combining it with doing control and
decision-making so we're gonna introduce
this example now with doing MC policy
evaluation and then we'll see it a few
times throughout class so what is this
example showing so in this example
they're going to be two actions so a one
is going to be straight lines and those
are all going to deterministically go to
what I'm going to call state s7 missus
state s1 s2 s3 s4 s5 s6 and what you can
see inside of the bubbles there is what
its feature value representation is so
remember I said that we would have a
state and then we could write it down as
a set of features so what does s1 look
like it looks like two two three four
five six seven so wait one is two and
wait eight is one so what does s2 look
like as two looks like 0 2 1 2 3 4 5
yeah
that's three looks like this and so on
until we get to s7 which looks like this
[Music]
so s7 looks a little bit different than
the rest of them that is the feature
representation of those states now
notice that it looks pretty similar to a
tabular representation in fact there are
more features than there are states so
there are only seven states here and
there are eight features that's
completely possible right like your
future representation could be larger
than the number of true states in the
world so then we have action a1 and
actually one always takes us from any
state deterministically to state s7 and
then we have action a2 which is denoted
by dot dot and what action a2 does is
with probability one over six it takes
you to state s I where I is in one to
six
so basically uniformly spread to your
across one of the first six states there
are only two actions either you
determinacy go to state s7 or if you
take the second action then you go to
one of the first six states with equal
probability and it's a pretty simple
control problem because there Awards a
zero everywhere for all actions so the
value function for this is zero because
there's no rewards anywhere and yet we
can start to run into trouble in some
cases so before we get to that part
let's first just think about what like a
Monte Carlo update would do and let's
just imagine also that there's some
additional small probability here that
from s 7 that we actually go to a
terminal state so like let's say you
know with probability 0.999 we stay in
a7 or like 0.99 we stay in s7 and point
0 1 we terminate and this is a slight
modification but I'm doing that just so
we can do it for the Monte Carlo case so
we can think of episodes ending so if
you're in state one through six you can
either go to s7 or you can stay in
states one through six if you're an s7
community go to States one through six
you can stay in s7 or you can terminate
all right so what what my didn't episode
look like in this case so let's imagine
that we were in state as one
to action a one that deterministically
gets us to state s7 actually before I do
that I'll specify we got zero reward
word with zero we went to s7 we took
action a1 we got zero reward we stayed
in s7 we took action a1 we got they were
wooden then we terminates that's our
episode so now we can think about what
our Monte Carlo update would be so our
Monte Carlo update in this case would be
let's start with state s1 and try to do
the Monte Carlo update so for state s1
the return is what sir so the return is
0 what is x1 I should tell you so let's
start with initializing all of our
weights to be 1 so what is our initial
estimate at the value function of state
s1 how many so it's all of the weights
r1 the state s1 representation is 2 0 0
0 1 3 that's right ok so and that's just
equal to R so then what does our update
look like and of course I would have to
tell you what alpha is so let's say
alpha is equal to 0.5 so what our
weights are gonna are change on the
weights is going to be equal to 0.5
times 0 minus 3 times our feature vector
for X our feature vector for X is 2 0 0
1 so that means that we're gonna get
basically minus 1.5 times to 0 or 1
minus 3 times minus 1.5 so notice this
is gonna give us an update for every
single weight but it's only gonna give
us an update for the weights that are
nonzero in this particular state which
is the first weight and weight and so
then if we were to actually get the new
weights so now
we're gonna have W is equal to W plus
Delta W then our new representation
would be minus two one two three four
five six nine point five so that would
be one update of Monte Carlo for the
first state now you would do this for
every single state in that episode so
you would then do it after the first
time you see it and the algorithm I have
defined before so we would next do this
for state s seven as well or the return
would also be zero but the value would
be something different so we would get a
different well actually in this
particular case the value is also three
it depends if you've already updated
your W then your your value will already
be different is already SGD per episode
our state we took per state yeah in the
previous slide we had the for every
state that every encounter does that
mean that very first visit it might have
a soda yes and it's within that specific
so we're gonna go to a new episode that
question is about through this first
visit we basically step along that
episode similar to what we did with
Monte Carlo before and the first time we
encounter a state in that episode we
update the weights using its return and
when we do that for every single unique
state in that episode the first time we
see it and then after all of that we to
get a new episode all right so this is
what would happen and you can see that
the changes can be fairly large because
we're comparing like the full return to
our value function and it depends of
course on what our alpha alpha is and
alpha can change over time and generally
we will want alpha to change over time
in order to get convergence this gives
an example of sir what Monte Carlo
updated would look like in this case
with linear value function approximated
okay so a natural question might be does
this do anything reasonable are we
guaranteed that this is going to
converge to the right thing and what
does the right thing mean here we're
constrained by our linear value function
approximator
so we're gonna say are we going to
converge to sort of like the best thing
in our
value function approximator okay before
we do this let's just talk for a second
about the distribution of states and how
that influences the result so if you
think back for maybe the first or second
lecture we talked about the relationship
between Markov processes Markov reward
processes and Markov decision processes
and we said that once you define a
particular policy than your Markov
decision process is actually a Markov
reward process where you can think of it
as a chain where the next state is
determined by your dynamics model where
you only use the action according to
your policy
so if you run that if you run your sort
of Markov chain defined by an MDP with a
particular policy you will eventually
converge to a probability distribution
over States and that distribution over
States is called the stationary
distribution it's a probability
distribution at saying sort of like what
percentage at the time you're going to
be in state one on average versus T two
etc has to sum to one because it's a
probability distribution you always have
to be in some state and it satisfies a
balance equation so it says that the
probability distribution over States
before I summed yeah I guess let me just
flip this I think it's a little bit
easier to think about it the other way
around we've got D of S prime is equal
to sum over s sum over a we're just
doing this I'm over a right now so that
we can be sure that we allow ourselves
to have stochastic policies so we look
at all the actions that we could take
under the current state and then we look
at where we could transition to on the
next state so we are in some
distribution over States we think of all
the actions we could take from each of
those states where we might transition
to and then that gives us a new
distribution over States s prime and
those two have to be identical so this
is often also thought about in terms of
a mixing property when you're Markov
chain has run for long enough this
bounds equation will eventually hold and
this is just that your distribution
nervous States on the previous time step
has to be exactly the same
your distribution number States on the
next time step after this process is
fully mixed and it just are telling you
on average you know how much time are
you spending in what's the probability
on any particular time step you're going
to be in a particular state this is not
telling us how long it takes for this
process to occur so this depends a lot
on the underlying dynamics of the system
so it might be that this takes millions
of steps until you reach the stationary
distribution or it might mix pretty
quickly it depends on the properties of
your transition matrix under the policy
I'm not going to get into any of that in
this class it's just important to know
that you can't it's not like you can
just wait a hundred steps and definitely
you're going to be in the stationary
distribution it depends on the problem
yes yeah well there's any proven bounds
on the mixing time of these type of
Monte Carlo methods not that I know of
there might be some it's a really tricky
issue often because you don't know how
long it will take to get to this sort of
stationary distribution there's a really
cool paper that just came out like a
month ago at Naropa that talks about how
when we're thinking about off policy
evaluation which we'll talk more about
later today instead of thinking about
per step ratios or whether you'll be in
a take a certain action and a certain
policy or not you can think about these
stationary distributions and the
difference between them in different
policies problems you often don't know
how long and whether your data has got
to that stationary distribution so would
also be really nice that there were easy
tests to tell if this was true that's
also really hard to know certain is
about right so I sort of gave a long
read Tony's as you know you gave a long
Prelude about saying like that things
might not converge but everything looked
fine there we got to go into that more
yes and we're gonna talk about the fact
that actually in the on policy setting
were registering policy evaluation
everything's gonna be fine it's only
when we get into the control case where
we're gonna be using data from one
policy to estimate the value of another
we're in this example and many others
things start to go awry so we'll use
this as a running example but right now
there's no reason for you
believe this is pathological okay so
this is the stationary distribution and
then the convergence guarantees are
related to that okay so what we're gonna
do is define the mean squared error of
our linear value function approximator
with respect to the stationary
distribution why is this reasonable well
because you probably care more about
your function approximated and error in
states that you visit a lot there's a
state that's really really rare probably
it's okay to have bigger error there you
want your overall mean squared error to
be defined on that stationary
distribution so this is the mean squared
sort of value prediction error and it
compares what we predict versus the true
value weighed by this distribution of
states and what we're assuming for right
now is that the approximation we're
using is a linear value function
approximator let me just note for
historical reasons that John does it
cyclist and Ben Ben Roy John is at MIT
and had the pleasure of him teaching me
probability which was great and then Ben
Ben Roy is here and was one of I think
John's PhD students or postdocs anyway
they in the about 1997 people were
getting really interested in whether or
not when you combine function
approximation with reinforcement
learning what happened and whether
things were good or bad and they're
responsible for this nice analysis so
it's the thing we have a linear value
function approximator what you can prove
is that if you do Monte Carlo policy
evaluation linear value function of
parks mater's you're going to converge
the wage which has the minimum mean
squared error possible it's gone best
you could hope for so this is saying in
the limit is you have lots and lots of
data then and you run this many many
many times then you can adjust converge
to the the best weights possible now
this air might not be zero because it
might be that your value function is not
approximate able with your linear set of
weights but it's gonna do the best job I
can so just gonna find the best it's
basically just doing the best linear
regression that you couldn't do on your
on your data so that's good that's you
know sort of a nice sanity check it's
gonna converge the best thing that you
could hope to do um some people have
been asking about ok well I've gonna be
the sort of incremental method and maybe
in some cases that's reasonable maybe
you're running like a customer
recommendation system and you're getting
data over time and you're updating this
estimator but in some cases you might
have access to just a whole bunch of
data from this policy and couldn't you
just do that kind of more directly and
the answer is yes so this is often
called batch Monte Carlo value function
approximator and the idea is that you
have a whole bunch of episodes from a
policy and the nice thing is now you can
just kind of analytically solve for the
best approximator so again our GIS are
going to be our unbiased sample that you
expected return and what you can do is
now n is just our set of data this is
really a linear regression problem we're
gonna use our unbiased samples with
estimates of the true value function
we're just going to find the weights
that minimize this mean squared error
you take the derivative you set it to
zero it's linear regression you can
solve for this analytically so a little
just like how we talked about you could
do policy evaluation analytically in
some cases you can also do it
analytically in this case for the linear
value of function approximator and note
again this is Monte Carlo we're not
making any markov assumptions we're just
using the full return this is also fine
and non Markov environments okay so what
we'd want to do this especially the
other inner one this generally has
higher computational cost X's can be a
very large matrix it may not be possible
to even write down xx it is all of your
data in the in the feature
representation form and it requires
taking a matrix inverse so that may not
be feasible if you've got you know huge
feature vectors and you know millions of
billions of customers Facebook can't do
this and through this directly and also
you know if you're doing this you could
do this sort of incrementally but you're
always refitting with all of your data
that also could be very expensive so
most of it's about memory and
computation if you have a really small
case it's probably a good thing to do
and also depends with you already have
all your data or not yeah some batch as
well right and that could help with
convergence and not having your
gradient estimations fluctuating prices
of course there's an in-between so you
could do you don't have to if you have
access to quite a bit of data you could
either do it completely incrementally or
all batch or you could do sub batches
and there's some nice work by my
colleagues and also us showing that in
terms of we get into deep learning there
can be a lot of benefits to doing sort
of some amount of this analytical aspect
over like you know a sub batch of data
because you're sort of particularly when
get into TD learning you're kind of
propagating information a lot more
quickly than you are if you're just
doing this sort of incremental slow
update because remember in TV learning
we're also kind of only doing like one
step of back up compared to kind of
propagating all of our information back
like we do with Monte Carlo all right so
now we're going to give you into
temporal difference learning and so
remember in temporal difference learning
we're gonna use both bootstrapping and
sampling Monte Carlo only use a sampling
to approximate the expectation TV
learning also use bootstrapping because
we don't have to wait till the end of an
episode we just bootstrap and like
combined in our estimate of expected
discounted sum of returns by using our
current value function so in this case
what we used to do is we would bootstrap
this is the bootstrapping part and our
what we often call our target is the
reward plus gamma times the value of the
next state and I remember the reason
this is sampling is we're sampling this
to approximate our expectation we're not
taking the full probability of s prime
given si and summing over all of s prime
so before we did this and we represented
everything as a table now we want to not
do that anymore
so let me just before we get to this let
me just remind us the three forms of egg
or they're the forms of approximation
we're going to have now now we're going
to have a function approximation
bootstrapping and sampling but we're
still on policy what do I mean by that
right now we're still just doing policy
evaluation which means we're getting
data from the policy that we're trying
to estimate its value turns out things
are just way easier in that case
when you're on policy and perhaps it
they should be somewhat intuitive it's
quite similar to the supervised learning
case supervised learning you're
generally assuming your data is all iid
our data is a little bit more
complicated than that but what our data
is closer to that in this case because
we have a single policy it's not served
this non-stationary aspect that comes up
when we start changing the policy so
right now we have these three forms of
approximation function approximation
bootstrapping sampling but we're still
on policy and mostly things are still
going to be okay in terms of convergence
so what does that look like we're again
going to sort of think about doing the
equivalent of supervised learning we'd
like to just have our states and the
Oracle tell us what the value is and fit
our function instead of having the
Oracle we're going to use our TD
estimates so we're gonna use our word
plus gamma times are approximate value
of the next date and that's gonna form
our estimate of what the true value is
okay and then we're gonna find the
weights to minimize the mean squared
error in that setting so if we do that
what we can see is that if we're doing
this through the linear case we write
this out it's just this is the TD target
just as a quick side note I'm gonna use
the word TD zero a lot we haven't talked
about it in this class but there's
actually a whole bunch of different
variants of TD which are often called T
V gamma and so if you're reading the
book that might be a little bit
confusing so I just want to be clear
that we're doing the TD zero variant
which is probably the most popular
there's a lot of other extensions trick
with simplicity we're just going to
focus on TD zero for now so this is the
TD target I this is our current estimate
and then we take the derivative in this
case that means that we're going to end
up plugging in our linear value function
approximator
for both our current state the next
state and looking at that difference
weighed by the feature vector so it
should look almost identical to the
Monte Carlo update except for the fact
that now we're bootstrapping so instead
of this being G as being the G return of
that we saw before for a particular
so now we're bootstrapping and we're
getting the immediate reward plus an
estimate of the discounted summer
rewards which were using our value
function approximator and to estimate so
this is what the TD learning a linear
value function approximation for policy
evaluation algorithm looks like again
we're gonna initialize our weight vector
we're gonna sample a tuple and then
we're going to update our weights so we
get to now update our weights after
every single tuple just like what we saw
for TD learning and what we can see here
is that we're just plugging in
particular estimator - our old estimator
times X so let's see what this looks
like on the Barrett example so again we
have the same state feature
representation as before state one is
two zero zero zero zero zero one
we still have zero words for everywhere
let's set our alpha equal to 0.5 now
we're in the case where we can say that
there is no terminal state because TV
learning can handle just continuous
online learning so we're just going to
assume that s 7 always stays instead s 7
under action a1 so a1 is the solid line
and a2 is the dashed and we're gonna
initialize our weights to 1 1 1 1 and
then let's look at this tuple so just
like the first couple we saw before
let's imagine we're in state 1 we took
action a1 we got a reward of 0 we went
to state s7 so why don't we take a
minute and you calculate what the new
weights would be after we do that update
and maybe compare back to the Monte
Carlo case in terms of how much they
have changed feel free to talk to a
neighbor
[Music]
just make this a little bit bigger so
it's easy to remember what s7 is
all right have they moved a lot a little
how much of the weights changed compared
to what we saw with TD with Monte Carlo
seen some people indicate smaller yes
that's right um okay so the the valid
the initial value of the states this is
gonna be so 4x of s1 times W it's still
gonna be 3/4 X s prime s prime is 7 if
we look up what that is this is also
gonna be 3 but now what we're gonna have
is we're gonna have Delta W is equal to
alpha times 0 plus 0.9 times 3 minus 3
that's going to be equal to alpha times
minus 0.3 so remember before it was
actually minus 3 so it was a much bigger
update and so then when we add that into
our our new weights we're gonna move our
weights but we're gonna move them much
smaller than we saw before this
shouldn't be too surprising it's sort of
consistent with what we saw for Monte
Carlo up Damien and TD learning TV
learning is only updating these sort of
smaller local changes like one state
action or where next highest state the
the Monte Carlo is saying this is an
episode full episodic return it's not
bootstrapping so it's a no really the
return from starting in state s1 is zero
so we're gonna move it a lot more here
it's saying okay I'm gonna pretend that
their return from state s1 is two point
seven which is close to three it's not
zero so when we move our our weights
over here the difference is going to be
much smaller than what we saw for Monte
Carlo which is similar to what we saw
without function apart
all right whatever theoretical
properties in this case pretty good so
these are also if you look at TV zero
you're gonna converge two weights which
aren't that's really quite as good as
Monte Carlo but they're within a
constant factor so they're gonna be 1
over 1 minus gamma of the minimum
possible so they're not quite as good as
Monte Carlo but they're pretty good and
depending on your discount factor and
the function approximator possible this
varies in terms of benefits so just to
check our understanding for a second
I've put up both of these results so one
says the Monte Carlo policy evaluator
converges to the minimum mean squared
error one possible under your linear
value function approximator and td0
converges to women one over one minus
gamma of this minimum curve so again
what is this minimum error that says if
you could pick any linear value function
approximator how good could that be at
representing your true value of your
policy so let's take just another minute
and this is a good one to talk to a
neighbor about if the value function
approximator is the tabular
representation what is them s PE for
both monte carlo and TD
we guaranteed to converge to the optimal
solutions optimal value for the true
value for via pie or not if it's not
clear what the question is feel free to
ask type of the representation what do I
mean by that I mean that there is one
feature for each state it's like a one
hot encoding so it's like the same
representations we saw for the first few
lectures where like for each state you
have a table lookup for that value of
that state I everything we're seen in
Russia knows about TV versus the t0
everything we're talking about in class
right now is td0
I'm using that because there are
multiple versions of TT and if you look
at the book they'll have TT lambda
sometimes 2 so I'm just making sure it's
clear so if you read other resources
you'll know which version of TD they're
not - all right well first question for
the if we're using a tabular
representation can we exactly represent
the value of a policy if we're using the
if we for every single state in the
world you can have a different different
table at representation can we exactly
represent the value of the policy yeah
we can so if the I if you have one
feature for every single state in the
world it's not gonna be practical we
can't actually do this but but you can
exactly represent the value of a policy
how could you do this you could simply
run the policy for every single state
I do Monte Carlo returns an average and
that would give you the true value of
the state so you could do it you could
represent expect you discounted summer
returns by representing that in every
single time table so that means that
this error is equal to zero because your
functional capacity is sufficient to
represent the value in expectation at
zero but in any episodes it's it's
different in this case if you have a
tabular representation and this is in
the limit so with infinite amounts of
data etc then this will be this will be
zero for every single state so this
equals zero for every state you will
converge to the right value for every
single state if you're using a tabular
representation and that's because if you
think of just having like literally
infinite amount of data and you run your
policy just you know infinite infinite
amount of times then for every state you
have an infinite number of trajectories
starting from that state and you could
write down that value separately in the
table so it'll be syrup so what that
means is that the the mean squared value
error for the Monte Carlo estimator is
zero if you're using a tabular
representation and because it's zero
that is exactly the same as the mean
squared value estimator for TD except
for so this is just equal to M SBE of
the monte carlo times 1 over 1 minus
gamma so that means that this is also
zero so if it's a tabular representation
just to sort of connect back to that no
none of these methods have any ER yeah
and neighbors
yes and question is you know where does
that 1 over 1 minus gamma constant come
from in the interest of time I'm not
going to go through it too much I
encourage you to read this as it's a
closed paper
intuitively there is error that's a
propagate propagating here because of
the fact that we're bootstrapping and so
if you have a function that what this
what this result is sort of trying to
highlight is that if your function
approximator actually has no error then
there's gonna be no difference between
Monte Carlo and TD because for both of
them the mean squared value error inside
of that sum the minimum over W is going
to be zero so it doesn't matter whether
you're using TD or Monte Carlo but if
that's not true like if you can't
actually exactly represent the value
function then you're gonna get error and
that error is gonna like basically you
could think of 1 over 1 minus gamma is
approximately the horizon H and
basically that's getting multiplied
because you're adding up these errors
and the reason those get added up is
because you're bootstrapping so you're
propagating that error back whereas
Monte Carlo doesn't suffer that in
general the mean squared error is taken
over a distribution of the states
I don't policy yeah yeah yeah under
specific policy but the only specific
one we've seen as a stationary
distribution do you ever use another one
like great question
my name is okay right now we're seeing
this under the stationary distribution
of the states that you're gonna reach
under the policy that you're exit that
you care about evaluating for that I
think that's the right choice because
that really is the states you're gonna
get to under this policy when we start
to think about control you might want
others like if you're gonna change your
policy all right so let's
I guess just briefly more on this I are
they faster is one of them better to my
knowledge that's not really understood
if you come across any literature on
that I'd love to hear it
practically TV often is better just
empirically often the bootstrapping off
and helps you a lot all right let's move
on briefly to control it's gonna be
pretty similar so instead of
representing the value function and
we're gonna represent the state action
value function which is what we saw
before when we wanted to often move from
policy evaluation to control
and now what we're going to do is we're
going to interleave sort of policy
evaluation with a value function
approximator with performing like an e
greedy policy improvement this is where
things can start to get unstable what
are we doing in this case we generally
involving function approximation
bootstrapping we often are also doing
sampling but really the really big issue
seems to be the off policy learning but
when we think about before we had this
nice stationary distribution or
converging to a stationary distribution
over states we're not going to be doing
that anymore because we're gonna be
using our changing our control policy
over time and so that's changing the
distributions of states that we
encounter and setting apart I often call
it the deadly triad I say once you start
combining function approximation and
bootstrapping and a policy learning
things start to get a little bit they
can fail to converge or converge to
something good alright but before we get
into that let's think about it
procedurally so now we're gonna have Q
functions that are parameterized by a W
and we can again do stochastic gradient
descent this is going to look almost
identical to what we had before
and again the stochastic gradient
descent can sample the gradient which
means for a particular state action pair
then we're gonna do these updates so
here what we're gonna do is we're gonna
represent our Q function by a set of
linear state action weights so that
means we're gonna have features that
sort of both encode the state in the
action so like what I saw when I was
turning left as my robot for example um
so it's gonna be a combination of these
two and then once we have that then
we're gonna just have a weight vector on
top of that for the Q so we're not
having separate weight vectors for each
action and said we're having features
that try to encompass both the state and
action themselves and then we can do our
stochastic gradient descent on top of
that so how does this work for like
Monte Carlo it's gonna look almost
identical to before we're just gonna
again use our return like now we're
gonna be defining returns from a
particular State
chené we're doing first visit the first
time we reach the state action in that
episode we look at the return that some
of rewards till the end of the episode
and we use that as our target because
that is our estimate of the Oracle data
key function and we update towards that
in sarsa we're going to use a TD target
so we're going to look at the immediate
reward of our tupple plus gamma times Q
of the next state that we encountered
and the action we took and say then
we're I'm gonna just plug that in and
then for Q learning it's gonna look
almost identical to Q learning except
for again we're going to plug in
function approximator is everywhere so
we're gonna plug in this remember is
gonna be a function of our X which is
going to be a function of s Prime and a
prime x RW where's here this is gonna be
a function of the state in action
everything's linear' and we're just
doing different forms of bootstrapping
and comparing whether or not we take it
max or not all right so I went through
that a little bit fast but it's
basically exactly analogous to the first
part which we sort of stepped through
more carefully it's ever everything's
with Q functions now why might this gets
weird or tricky so TD with value
function approximation is not really
following a gradient I don't have time
to go into it ton of details on that
today but there's a nice some nice
explanations on this in chapter 11 so
certain Umberto Chapter 11 it's a great
resource and we also have lecture notes
available online
um and so informally we're sort of doing
this interleaving of doing this like
approximate sample bellman back up
combined with what's often known as a
projection step because we're trying to
sort of project our value function back
into the space of representable
functions and intuitively for why this
might start to be a problem is that the
bellmen operator we showed is a
contraction like when we're doing
dynamic programming we showed that if
you do bellman operat bill and backups
you're guaranteed to converge to a fixed
point when you do the value function
approximator it can be an expansion
expansion mean well what a contraction
just as a reminder what a contraction
side is let's say for an operator that's
a contraction if you apply this operator
this is an operator like the bellman
equation going back up if you apply it
to two different value functions the
distance between this could be like a
max norm or something like that is less
than or equal to the previous distance
which means as you apply this operator
the distance between your old value
function you value function keeps
getting smaller and smaller and smaller
and eventually get to a fixed point the
problem is this now we're not doing that
anymore
it's more like we're doing like a V and
then we do some sort of projection
operator I'm just going to call it kind
of a weird P so this is the projection
operator it means when you compute your
new value function it may no longer lie
in your value function approximator
space you're gonna have to refit it back
into that space and when you do that
that operator itself can be an expansion
for those of you that are interested in
some of the early sort of discussions of
this Jeff Gordon has a really nice paper
on averages from 1995 where they talked
about how linear value function
approximator is can be an expansion so
the bellman back up is fine it's a
contraction but when you do this
approximation you might expand the
distance and that's one of the problems
okay so if we go back to our Baird
example and think about this a little
bit more in terms of the control case so
let's imagine that we have a setting
where you have two different policies
and the first policy and this is the
policy that you want to evaluate you
always take the solid line so you always
take a 1 and in your behavior data this
is the data that you're this is the
policy you're using to gather data you
take a 2 with 6/7 of the time and you
take a 1 1/7 of the time gamma is 0.99
and what you do is you generate a whole
bunch of data so you generate data under
your behavior policy
so there's some really cool work on how
you deal with I'm sort of correcting for
the day that you're getting versus the
data you want to evaluate let's imagine
we don't go into any of that which i
think is super cool and instead we're
just gonna do something super simple
which is we're gonna throw out all the
data that doesn't match so imagine you
just throw away data if a it's not equal
to PI of s so you generated all these
data points so what does it what do I
mean by data points here we had si R as
Prime so you take all these tuples if it
turns out that the action that was taken
there is not the same as the policy you
want to evaluate that where you're only
ever taking a 1 just throw out that
tupple you don't update so now all of
your remaining data is consistent with
your policy so let's imagine then you
tried to do TD learning with that data
the problem is you can diverge and what
do I mean by that it means that your
weights can blow up super interesting
why this happens
the main intuition for it is that your
distribution data is not the same as the
data that you would get under your
desired target policy in particular if
you were actually to run the the policy
you care about pi what would happen
let's say you start off in state s1 you
take a one that determinately gets you
to state s7 they're gonna stay in a7 for
a really long time because it's
deterministic so you'd get like s1 I
said the notice I've been let's say even
you did this maybe you maybe it was an
episodic case and you have multiple
episodes you'd still have cases where
you'd like have very little bit amount
of data about s these SS and lots of
data about s7 but in the date of you get
from your behavior policy because a
bunch of the time it takes a - it'll
keep teleporting you back to one of s1
through s6 which means the distribution
of you data that data you have looks
very different the distribution of
states you visit looks very different
than the data that you get in the states
you'd visit under PI and that is the
problem if you if you don't account for
this mismatch then the values can
diverge
even though they're all sort of
compatible all in the sense that you are
only ever using state action pair if you
took the action under your desired
policy and this sort of issue can also
come up when using cue learning and
you're doing generally like updating
this policy over time so in terms of
this just to briefly summarize before we
we finish in the tabular case everything
converges it's beautiful
in the linear case I mean by this I mean
that can shatter you basically converge
but you might I there might be some
oscillation but q-learning like where
you're doing this off policy aspect can
diverge and once we get into nonlinear
value function approximation everything
like mostly all bets are off
no this is a little bit of an
oversimplification there has been a huge
amount of work and huge amount of
interest in this because everyone wants
to do function approximation with RL so
we can tackle real problems and so over
the last like one or two decades it's
been a huge amount of work on this and
there are some algorithms now that do
have convergence guarantees and there's
some super cool really recent work where
they're looking at batch RL which can
converge with nonlinear approximator x'
so there's definitely a lot of work on
this that we're not going to get to I
just want to highlight that it's a
really important issue not just whether
it converges but what it converges to
like you might converge to a point which
is a really bad approximator
so it's stable it doesn't you're double
your weights aren't blowing up but it's
just a really bad approximator and some
of the critical choices here your
objective function in your future
representation so just before we close I
think this is a really nice figure from
set and umberto what they're showing
here is you can think of it as like you
have this plane which is where you can
represent all of your linear value
function approximator z-- and what
happens when you do a belmont update or
like you do a TD backup is that you're
going to now sort of have a value
function that might not be representable
in your plane and you're going to you
can project it back and these different
you can quantify different forms of
error different basically this allows
you to fight
different objective functions that
you're trying to minimize in order to
find the best approximator and we've
seen one today which is sort of this
meet minimum mean squared error
approximator essentially over the like
these bellman errors but that's not the
only choice and it's not necessary even
the best choice because it might be that
the one that has the smallest error
there is not the same one that has the
best performance in your real problem so
that's a little bit fast but it's super
interesting it's covered in set number
two and eleven if you want to go into
more detail just really quick what are
the things you should understand you
should be able to implement these ones
on linear value function approximator
both for policy evaluation and control
should understand whether or not things
can converge in the policy evaluation
case when the solution has zero error
nonzero error and you should just
understand qualitatively what are the
issues that can come up so that some of
these solutions may not always converge
it's this combination of function
approximation bootstrapping and a policy
learning all right so that's enough to
sort of get started with the homework
two that we're gonna be releasing this
with today and then on next week we're
gonna start to talk about deepening
Thanks